back of my fraternities I eventually
became president of the fraternity and
every single season they would have new
pledges and at week two like clockwork
everyone would revolt and say this sucks
this is too hard this isn't what I
signed up for ETC I remember when it was
my turn to be president I gave them a
little bit of a different talk and so I
said hey guys who here thought this was
going to be easy and no one raised their
hands okay so you all thought this was
going to be hard right and they were
like yeah this is what heart feels like
soak this in right now because this is
what it is and if you can get through
this then you know that when other hard
things come up in your life you can know
the hard you've been through in your
past and that's going to give you the
strength to do whatever you want
afterwards a lot of people are going
through hard times right now and if you
wanted to make a million dollars you
wanted to make you know a hundred
thousand dollars you want to make 100
million dollars did you think it was
going to be easy probably not and
whenever I get to that point I always
think to myself this is where most
people stop and this is why they don't
win